كشفت الاستخبارات الامريكيه ان لديها
تقارير تشير الى ان الجيش الصيني يخطط
للسيطره على تايوان بحلول عام 2027 وتشهد
المنطقه توترا متصاعدا بعد اعلان الصين
فرض حظر جوي للنصف ساعه شمال تايوان
الاسبوع المقبل بالتزامن مع التشديد
الرئيس الصيني على ان بلاده ستدافع عما
وصفها بسيادتها الاقليميه وستطور قدراتها
العسكريه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف نقرا المشهد
الراهن في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ في
ظل استمرار التحركات العسكريه الصينيه في
مضيق تايوان وعزم بيجين فرضا منطقه حظر
للطيران في شمال الجزيره ولي مدى تاثر
الصينيون بالسيناريو الروسي في اوكرانيا
وما حقيقه رغبتهم في السيطره على تايوان
ثم كيف ينظر الامريكيون الى المشهد الراهن
وما هي خطتهم للحيلوله دون تفجر الصراعي
في بحر الصين وما يحمله من تداعيات على
المشهدين الدولي والاقليمي وما الذي تحمله
هذه الازمه من رسائل بشان طبيعه الدوري
الامريكيه حول العالم واولويات واشنطن
تجاه مختلفه قضايا المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اجواء ساخنه تسود منطقه مضيق تايوان هذه
الايام تقف وراءها تحركات عسكريه صينيه
بلغت شوطا متقدما باعلان حظر للطيران شمال
البلاد التي تعتبرها الصين جزءا لا يتجزا
منها الرئيس الصيني قال ان بيجين ستدافع
عن سيرتها الاقليميه وحقوقها البحريه
واضاف انه يجب تعزيز التدريب العسكري
والتطوير الشامل للقوات الصينيه تحسبا لاي
قتال فعلي
امريكيا قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي ان
هدف الولايات المتحده هو السلام والامن
والاستقرار وليس الدخول في حرب بارده
جديده ولا احتواء الصين
مدير وكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه
الامريكيه قال في معرض التعليق على تقارير
عن خطط صينيه لغاز تايوان انه من الضروري
ان تاخذ الولايات المتحده رغبه الصين في
السيطره على تايوان بجديه بالغه حتى ان لم
يكن الصراع العسكري هو النتيجه الحتميه
لذلك
[موسيقى]
ليه مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من واشنطن
الدكتور ديفيدني نائب ومساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكيه السابق لشؤون الامن القوميه في
اسيا وانا رئيس البعثه الامريكيه في الصين
سابقا
ومن بيجين
والباحث السياسيه ومن واشنطن محمد
المنشاوي الكاتب الصحفي المختص بالشان
الامريكي وابدا بضيفنا من واشنطن
الفان 2017 هو ما تم توقعه امريكيا
لاستيلاء الصين على تايوان على اي اساس
بني هذا التوقع
كان ذلك على اساس تقديرات الوضع العسكري
الصيني حاليا مقارنه بوضعهم في تايوان
وتعريف مع استيلاء يعني في الواقع امر صعب
تحديده وهناك كثير التساؤلات حول هذا
الامر واهمها ما هي اراده تعيوان ماذا
تريد تايوان وشعب تايران ماذا يريدون هذا
امرا على حكام ان حكام يحاولن ان يكسروا
اراده شعبه تايوان ومقاومتهم ولحسن الحظ
انهم فاخذ ذلك وشعبه تايوان اصلح اكثر
عدائيه يوما بعد اخر ازاء الصين وكلما
كانت اراده قويه في تايوان كما شاهدنا في
اوكرانيا عندما يحاول تحاول دوله غزوه بلد
الشعب يعارض ذلك سيكون من الصعب جدا تحقيق
النصر عليهم
سيد رونغوان ما هو هدف كل هذه المناورات
والتحركات العسكريه الصينيه في مضيق
تايوان ما هو الهدف النهائي منها
[موسيقى]
على تايوان كيف يمكن الربط بينما يجري في
مضيق تايوان وبين السيناريو الروسي
الاوكراني
تحيه طيبه اعتقد ان الحاله الاوكرانيه
اسهل هناك حدود بريه طويله سهلت من غزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا وسيطره على الثلث
الاراضي الاوكرانيه حتى الان لكن في
الحاله التايوانيه هي جزيره تبعد اكثر من
100 كيلو عن البر الصيني واعتقد ان هناك
استعداد ضخمه جدا في تايوان واستعداد لمثل
هذا الغزو الذي اعتقد انه لن يحدث
العقيده العسكريه الصينيه منذ استقلال
الدوله سنه 49 تقول اننا سنضم تايوان
قريبا الرئيس ماو الرئيس دينج شياوبينج
الرئيس كلهم يقولون ذلك لكنهم يدركون
عواقب مثل هذه الخطوه على المصالح الصينيه
ومكانتها في العالم
الولايات المتحده والغرب وليس الولايات
المتحده فقط رئيس حلف الناتو كان في
اليابان وكوريا منذ اسابيع يؤكد على الدعم
الغربي لت وعلى وقوفه معها في رغبتها في
البقاء دوله مستقله على ما هو الحال عليه
واعتقد ان ايضا تظهر في كل مناسبه للصين
تكلفه اي تحرك عسكري انها لن تقف مكتفه
الايدي وحتى وان لم تعبر عن ذلك بسرعه
واضحه
اعود مره اخرى لضيفي من بيجين السيد
رونجوان يعني تقول انه هذه الرسائل
للداخل الاوكراني للانفصاليين في الداخل
والرسائل للخارج ايضا بان الصين مصممه على
الحفاظ على سيادتها ووحده اراضيها على
اساس انه تايوان جزء من الاراضي الصينيه
لكن ما هي ما هو العامل الذي او الحدث
الذي اذا وقع فان كل ما رايناه من مناورات
وتدريبات سيتحقق في ارض الواقع
طبعا هذه
المناوعات كلها مرات تاتي بعد الاستفزازات
المستمر من
الانفصاليين وكذلك القوه الداعمه لها من
الخارج
وكذلك هنا في
خلفيه حاليا فهناك
يعني ازدياد للقوه الوطنيه الصينيه وكذلك
الازدياد للقدره الجيش التحرير الشعبي
الصيني للتنفيذ مهمه
يعني ما هو الاجراء الذي اذا اتخذته
تايوان ترى الصين انه لا يمكن السكوت عليه
ولا بد من التدخل العسكريا
يعني
هو اي اشاعات من بارس
تقصد اجراءات من اذا اتخذت تايوان ما هو
الاجراء يعني ما هو ما هي الحاله التي
ستقرر فيها الصين انه حان الوقت للدخول
الى تايوان وضمها الى البر الصيني
طبعا في اي محاولات يعني لاعلان استقلال
او هناك
الدخول القوات الامريكيه في الجزيره وكذلك
يعني
الاستقلال يعني في اي حاله من اعلان
الاستقلال والسعي الاستقلال او دخول
القوات الامريكيه في الجزائر اعود الى
ضيفنا للسيد الدكتور ديفيد سيدني هل
الولايات المتحده جاهزه لهذا السيناريو
سيناريو تفجر صراع في مضيق تايوان
او تعمل على منعه ما هي خطتها لمنع تفجر
هذا الصرع استمعت الى ضيفنا من بيجين يقول
انه اي اعلان للاستقلال او اي دخول لقوات
امريكيه الى الجزيره باعداد تزعج الصين
هذا سيعني بلا شك تدخلا صينيا ما خطه
الولايات المتحده لمنع وصول الامور الى
هذا المستوى من
الصراع
الولايات المتحده وموقفها واضح ومستمر منذ
منذ حوالي حوالي خمسين سنه في الولايات
المتحده لا تدعم استقلال التايوان ولايه
المتحده تسعه الى حل سلمي بين الاطراف من
جانبي الضيق وانه الولايات ذاتها ملتزمه
بان تقدم الدفاع عن تايوان لا يتعرض لاي
عمل بالقوه لحل المساله اذا الولايات
المتحده جانب السلام والثانيا لا يتعلق
بالبيت المتحده والصين فقط هناك
اليابان وكوريه ودول اخرى في اسيا لها
علاقه بل حتى هناك في نطاق اوسع هذا كله
يحصل في وقت نجد ان القياده الصينيه او
الزعيم الصين
يواجه مشاكل كثيره لديه مشاكل اقتصاديه
وقت اساءت التعامل مع جائحه كوفيد والسكان
الصينيون الان في انخفاض حاليا والصين
تواجه نزاع عدوديه مع الهند وايضا الصين
تقوم باسراء اراضيك في جنوب في في بحر
جنوب الصين رغم ان المحكمه الدوليه قالت
مخالفه قانون الدولي الكثير من الدول ترى
ان الصين
على انها قوه صديقه اما فرعونها ذئب يرتدي
ملابس الحملان وبالتالي في الصين الان
تواجه مشاكل كثيره وانا الشجم بين يحاول
التعامل مع هذا بايقاف نيران الشعور
القومي في البلاد وهذا امر خطر جدا واما
ان يستطيع السيطره عليه
وماذا عن خطه الولايات المتحده
انا اريد ان اعرف ما هي خطه الولايات
المتحده لمنع الصعيد الصراع في مضيق
تايوان الى المستوى الذي يحدث فيه نزاع
مسلح
الامريكي حول تايوان لطالما كان واضحا
وليس فيه اي غموض استراتيجيه ذلك انه يكون
دائما لو ان الصين هاجمت المتحده
تدافع ولكن طبعا لا نعلم بالضبط وعن ما هي
الخطط لتحقيق ذلك والكل ملتزمين اليابان
والصين عفوا اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه كلهم
ملتزمين ذلك كل غربي جنوب شرق اسيا وغربي
اسيا كلهم يعارضون اي تحرك عسكري تقوم به
الصين ضد تايوان وبالتالي لو ان الصين
قامت مثل هذا العمل فانا ستعاني معاناه
كبيره ليس فقط كمواجهه عسكريه والواقع لا
ينبغي فقط جانب العسكري فهناك القضايا
السياسيه الاكبر وهي اهم فلو هاجمت الصين
دوله مارقه اكثر ما هي عليه روسيا الان
تحمل ذلك لا تحمل قطع العمل وبالتالي اذا
ما استخدمت قوه عسكريه ضد تايوان اعود
للاستاذ محمد من شوب من واشنطن هل بالفعل
هنالك يعني ضيفنا من واشنطن يقول انه
هنالك استراتيجيه امريكيه واضحه وانه
الولايات المتحده لن تتدخل الى اذا تدخلت
الصين لكن هل المجريات الامور تسير على
هذا المنوال
اعتقد ان الموقف الامريكي الرسمي هو رضع
الصين وتخويفها من القيام بخطوه عسكريه عن
طريق التواجد العسكري الضخم جدا في منطقه
المحيطه الهندي والهادي هناك اغلب الوقت
حملتي طائرات اضافه الى عشرات الالاف من
الجنود في اليابان وفي كوريا مستعدين
لتدخل اذا حدث تطور عسكري ايضا هناك
استراتيجيه امريكيه في تطويق الصين
بتحالفات عسكريه تقيدها
ترضعها اذا فكرت بكين في غزو تايوان هناك
التحالف الثلاثي مع استراليا وبريطانيا
ونقل تحالف الرباعي مع اليابان والهند
واستراليا ايضا وهناك العلاقه العسكريه
المتزايده بشده مع الفلبين وراينا هناك
اربع قواعد عسكريه جديده لوشن تم افتتاحها
مؤخرا في الفلبين فاعتقد ان ارد على
العسكري الامريكي الضخم في المنطقه هو
الرضع الرئيسي للمنع الصين من غزوه طيران
وازهار التكلفه العاليه لبكين ان ارادت او
فكرت في خطوه عسكريه لن يكون هناك لن تكون
نتائج ايجابيه بالضروره للصين
فيما يتعلق بالنموذج الروسي في اوكرانيا
يعد مره اخرى الى ضيفنا من بيجين رون هو
هل هذا نموذج نموذج يصلح
مقارنته اصلا بما يجري في مضيق تايوان
بالنسبه الى مساله فهي مختلفه تماما ان
يعني ازمه اوكرانيا اولا اوكرانيا دوله
المستقله ذات السياده
ليست دوله يعني لا توجد في العالم سوى 13
دوله يعترف بها والذي علاقات الدبلوماسيه
ولكن الامم المتحده
والمجلس الدولي وكذلك معظم الدول في
العالم حتى الولايات المتحده يعترف باسم
مبدا صيني واحد لا تعترف بها دوله السياده
وثم
الجزيره ايضا مختلفه هل هناك حدود طويل
بريه بين
الدور الاوروبيه
والاوكرانيا ولكن
الجزيره يعني الجزيره وحولها المياه في
اربعه اتجاه حاليا
الجيش التحرير الشعبي الصيني الان في
تدريبات يوم كل يوم من اجل الحصار وتطبيق
الجزيره اذا حصلت الحرب فيكون الجيش
الحريه الشعبي قدره لقطع امدادات الاسلحه
من الخارج وكذلك امدادات
الغذائيه من الخارج وكذلك قطع الطريق
الحروب للانفصاليين
الامر مختلف تماما فنعلم هذا يجعل الغزو
الجزيره والسيطره عليها اكثر سهوله يعني
قرار اسهل من الدخول الى اوكرانيا بالنسبه
للقياده الصينيه
كان اسهل ولكن الاكبر حاجز كان منضوس يعني
سنوات طويله اكبر حاجز هو التدخلات
العسكريه الامريكيه فهناك الحملات
الطائرات امريكيه كل مره عند حدوث اي ازمه
او الاحتكاك الصيني الامريكيه
الولايات المتحده على النشر
الطائرات الحاملات الطائرات لاستعراض
القوه
لترغيب او تحديدات تحديد الصين باستخدام
ولكن حاليا
الوضع مختلفه لان هناك ازدياد كبير لقدراء
العسكريه الصينيه من اجل ارتفاعه سيادتها
ووحده اراضيها ممكن ان نرى ايضا هذه المره
المناورات ايضا يعني تركز على ردع الشعب
الصيني لاي تدخلات الخارجيه التدخلات
المحتمله من القوات الامريكيه للجزيره
وهناك قوات صواريخ الصينيه الجاهزه وهناك
ايضا حامله حامله طائرات الصينيه ايضا
تستطيع ان تعمل تنفس مهمه ردع اي تدخلات
عسكريه امريكيه يعني هذه الازمه برمتها
وعدل ضيفنا من واشنطن
الدكتور ديفيد سيدني هي هي ليست مجرد ازمه
معزوله عن السياق العالمي وهو السياق ان
الولايات المتحده تريد مواجهه الصين
باعتبارها القوه القادمه في القرن الجديد
هل هل هذا الامر
يمكن منعه يمكن منعه عن طريق مضيق تايوان
او حتى بهذه التحالفات انه الصين تصبح هي
القوه الكبرى في العالم
اولا
الجميع يركز اكثر ما ينبغي على الجانب
العسكريه في حين ان القرايه وجوانب
السياسيه هي الاهم ان الصين باستخدام
قبضتها ومحاوله الضربه تايوان
العسكريه ولكن ذلك يجعل الناس الشعوب فيه
دائما يتقلى ابتعدوا عنا ايها الصينيين
وهذا ايضا التشبيه باوكرانيا مهم صحيح
ايضا فما يقوم به الصينيون هو جعل الناس
الشعب في تايوان اكثر عدائيه ضد بيجين
ويحلقون المزيد من الاعباء وكلما زاد
استخدام القوه وتهديد القوه ثم نصين زادت
كراهيه لهم طبعا الولايات المتحده تدعم
قوه تايوان الامر لا يتعلق مواجهه الصين
بل يتعلق الامر بالسلام الصين تقول انها
تريد استخدام القوه بين ملازم المتحده قول
لا لا تستخدم القوه الولايات المتحده تقول
السلام والمفاوضات على الصين ان تصغي الى
طريق السلام وطريق النقاشات وتستوقف عن
استخدام القوه يعني او تقدير التهديد
بالقوه الولايات المتحده تعترف بسياسه
الصين واحده تعترف بان ثوان جزء من الصين
ما هي فكره الولايات المتحده لان تصبح
فعلا تايوان جزر من الصين كيف يمكن تحقيق
ذلك
والصين تواجده وتعايشاه سلميه في جانبي
المضيق جزئيا بفضل الدعم الامريكي
لبيان شنغهاي الذي يعترف بانك صين واحده
ولكن كل جزء من مضيقه تايوان لديه فكره
مختلفه عن طيور الجنه
في المستقبل طالما ان الصله استعمل القوه
ولا تلجا هذا الوضع لا ينبغي للصين ان
تفكر حتى حتى تفكر فيه باستقرار القوه على
الصيانه سقف بالسلام وتطبق شعارها
السلام من اجل التنميه من المؤسف ان الصين
تستعمل القوه وتهدد الناس بقبضتها هذا ليس
بالطريقه لائقه لدوله مسؤوله في التصرف
استاذ محمد المنشاوي هل ما يجري في مضيق
تايوان هو جبهه جبهه من ضمن جبهات
معركه الرياده في العالم
ام انه قضيه لها خصوصيتها وغير مرتبطه
اساسا
بهذه القوه بمساله المعركه على رياده
العالم
تايوان هي القضيه الاكثر سخونه في التنافس
الصيني الامريكي المحتدل الان والمستمر
والذي سيستمر على مدار القرن الحادي
والعشرين الصين قوه صاعده وتحقق تنميه
اقتصاديه كبيره جدا وتنفس الوقت المتحده
اقتصاديا الان لكن تبقى عسكريا اكثر تقدما
بعده سنوات
العسكريه الصينيه الوضع العسكري الصيني
لكن الاهم ان تايوان بها اكبر مصانع في
العالم لصناعه اشباه الموصلات التي تستخدم
في كل وسائل المعيشه والتكنولوجيا الحديثه
وهناك شركه واحده شركه تايوان لصناعه
اشبال الموصلات تصنع 90% من الموصلات
الاكثر تقدما في العالم واعتقد ان هذا هو
احد اسباب الدعم الامريكي المتناهي
لتايوان واستقلالها فاذا سيطرت الصين على
تايوان وعلى هذه الشركه بالتبعيه
ستتغير منظومه توازن القوى العالم ي لصالح
الصين شكرا جزيلا لك من واشنطن محمد
المنشاوي الكاتب الصحفي المختص بالشهاده
الامريكي ومن بيجين رونجوان الاعلامي
والباحث السياسي ومن واشنطن الدكتور ديفيد
سيدني نائب ومساعده وزير الدفاع الامريكي
السابق للشؤون الامن القومي في اسيا ونائب
رئيس البعثه الامريكيه في الصين سابقا
شكرا
الخبر في امريكا
[موسيقى]